hey Samuel here and I'm just out feeding
the Ducks with my baby girl and wifey
and today is the day when my or one of
my lease option agreements has just come
to an end so the deal was actually four
years ago when I secured the option and
I said I would buy in five years for
seventy six thousand pounds now it's now
worth 102 thousand pounds so it's gone
up considerably in value and the
arrangement on the option because
sometimes people say you know do they
have to sell it do you have to buy it
well with an option agreement you have
the option not the obligation to buy it
but if you if you can pull out can they
pull out and the answer is if it's been
drawn applies to us to properly no they
can't pull out I have to sell it so what
I normally do is I already say that 12
months prior to the completion date or I
will give them my intent of whether I'm
gonna buy or not so it's actually been
four years and I've given my intent that
I will buy it because of course I'm
buying it for 76 it's now with 102 it
makes sense so my question now is how am
I going to find out this property
am I going to buy it just straight
forward you know put down 25% of
seventy-six thousand pounds and it's
just like I've got a really good B&B
deal or I'm only gonna buy it and
refinance it I've been speaking to my
finance guy the problem is with
refinancing it is you need to have shown
that you've added value so if I just say
hey I bought it for 76 but it's worth
102 can I please refinance it now
they're gonna they're going to ask what
value about it because a house is only
worth what someone is prepared to pay
for it so in the surveyors mind it's
worth 76 if that's what I paid for it
little tip is it can cause complications
and confusion telling the lender that
you've done an option so it's best to
just buy it as a straight sale because
some lenders don't like the fact that
you've previously you know done option
on it it's a little tip so I'm not sure
what to do now I'll probably buy it
through a company what I might do is I
might buy it even though it's in good
condition and it's renting out five
hundred pounds a month and no I put a
new kitchen a new bathroom and put some
carpets and naturally spend like eight
ten thousand pounds doing a refurb and
then see if I can persuade my lender to
let me refinance which will mean I can
pull all my money out I probably I might
do that
so yeah options but the thing is when
you're in a position where you're buying
a property that that's considerably
below market value
I'm in a very strong position now
because whatever I do I'm gonna make
money people that say oh if it doesn't
go up in value well I've been making 300
pounds a month positive cash flow for
the last four years if it was still only
worth 76 at this point I'd walk away but
it's not so hope that's kind of giving
you guys some info on - Lease Option
agreements what to do when it comes to
its end another thing I could do is I
could buy it for 76 and then resell it
for 102 but then you know I've made a
little bit of money before the time you
take off the stamp duty in the fees I'd
probably rather see a time hold on to it
so if you've got any questions or
experience or anything comments on lease
option agreement you've got some
comments Roubaix she's got some comments
then put them below and I look forward
to answering those as best I can
god bless see you next time